- Put a vibrator on the
Roomba, welcome to Westworld.
(intense electronic music)
- Welcome to Spoiler Party,
where we talk about movies,
TV, and other stuff.
Today, we are watching
Westworld, the Season One finale.
Who has seen it?
(ding ding)
Okay.
- We watched it together.
- Yeah we did.
- I have never seen an
episode of the show at all.
- Do you know what it's about?
- It's about a adult-ish
theme park where its
western, late 1800s, where people can go
and live out their cowboy fantasies.
- When you say,
"adult-ish" I automatically
think something sexual.
- Yeah, you can go and
have sex with these robots.
- Oh!
(dramatic orchestral music)
- Are these the kind of
robots where if you rip off
their fake skin it's just metal?
- No it's this white silicon thing.
- Oh so they're like 3-D printed.
- It's weird it's like
their dipped in milk.
- We talked about the milk baths,
but before that they were
more robotic looking,
like she is now.
- Okay, so she's like a 3GS
and now they're at an X.
- Yeah.
- Yet again, another unrealistic
female body standard.
(laughs)
- She's not even all skin and bones--
- She's all bones.
(laughs)
- Are there black robots?
Or is it very historically accurate?
- The owner of the brothel is black.
- I'd be friends with
her because that's where
I'd wanna work.
- She's very cool.
- You wanna work at the brothel?
- Oh no, I got brothel
confused with saloon.
- Oh so it's both?
- I'd like to be the
performer in the saloon.
Big Tit Daisy!
(laughs)
Singin' a number, drinking
everybody under the table,
a-one, two, three, four.
- Liza Minnelli over here.
- That's who I'm gonna be
for Halloween next year.
A saloon hoe.
- Big Tit Daisy?
- Big Tit Daisy.
- Just workin' at the good ole brothel.
- Just workin' at the
brothel, tryin' to make
an honest living.
- That's not an honest living--
- It's an honest living!
- You're name's Big Tit Daisy.
(laughs)
- It's not honest at all.
- Is it wrong?
I mean it's not wrong!
I'm Big Tit Daisy.
- This place feels more
real than the real world.
Except it isn't because you
can't really fight back.
- Do they like screen
people before they're like,
"You can go into this world?"
- No, it's all just money.
You got cash?
Welcome to Westworld.
- Laying on top of a hill
with a friend, looking over
at a bunch of people,
that would be what I did.
- Brokeback Mountain.
- Yeah, actually, exactly.
- Brokeback Mountain?
- I'd Brokeback Mountain the
(bleep) Out of Westworld.
- Okay, what are some Pickup Lines
that the characters would use
to pick someone up in a bar?
- You like milk?
(Laughs)
(beep)
- I would look at Westworld
as really nice practice for me
and I would go there and I
would try to hit on robots
and just see what lines work.
- But they're not a good gauge of whether
or not it would work, right?
- They seem human-like.
- I guess.
- Is it consensual sex?
- Not all the time, you do bad things.
- It's the same question
as, "Is it consensual sex
if you have sex with a vibrator?"
- Hmmmmm.
- Is it?
Because the vibrator
doesn't talk back to me.
- You could get a vibrator that does.
- Neither one has consciousness.
- There's gotta be talking vibrators.
- I don't even know.
- There's gotta be vibrators that'll
read you a book or something.
- Gotta little speaker in it.
- It's like hooked up to Audible.
- Yeah, Audible.com
- So what would your pickup line be?
- Oh I don't know yet,
I would need the drive
to think about it.
- Think about James Marsden.
- Hey James.
- James Marsden just shot
every other robot in the park.
It's just you and him.
Now pick him up.
(laughs)
- You know what--
- So you're standing, there's
dead bodies all around you,
covered in blood, go!
- Oil and blood everywhere.
- James, you've been through a lot today.
- Uh-huh.
- You seem tense.
(laughs)
Let's go work out some
of that tension on a bed
with you on top of me.
This is why I can't pick up--
- I don't know if you need
to specify the position,
I think "on the bed" you were there.
- Don't say with you on top of me,
just work out some tension?
- I think that's a better
start than with you on top.
- Resume the show!
(laughs)
- Oh look at that (bleep).
- Oh is that a (bleep)?
Show me the (bleep)!
Rewind!
- No.
- I wanna see that (bleep)!
- There's plenty of (bleep) To be seen.
- Are you sure?
- Yes.
- In this there's a lot of (bleep)?
- There's plenty of (bleep).
(Dramatic Music)
- Is that him?
- Yeah.
- Oh my god!
- William.
- What!
- That's awesome, look at you guys.
- This is very exciting.
- So if you had to describe
something at Westworld
in a Tweet, or your experience
at Westworld in a Tweet,
what would it be?
- It's like that bad Kermit
meme where it's like,
Good Kermit is like, "GO have
fun at the amusement park,"
and then it's Bad Kermit like,
"Have sex and murder everyone
and try to take over the world."
- This is basically the
real life Grand Theft Auto--
(laughs)
- (bleep) !
- Penises.
- Robot (bleep).
(Gunshots)
- What the hell is this show?
- That's the end?
- Yeah.
- Shit.
- I have so many questions.
I'm curious about season two.
I saw something people are talking about,
if Ford is really dead
or not, Anthony Hopkins.
- Yeah, right, if that was a host.
- Because you can just make a fake you
and then he was murdered
to cause the chaos
but Ford is really somewhere.
- I like that idea a lot.
- I like that.
- Just saying.
- I bet the very first scene
of season two takes place
in a different world.
If not Shogun World then some other world.
- That's gonna be the
effect of Westworld had
on this new world.
- It's like the Hunger Games,
how one district's rebellion
causes like other rebellions.
- I wonder if they're gonna
find out that all of them
have always been robots except for William
and then at the very end
we find out that William
was in a Truman Show type thing,
once he figures that out,
that he's been played the whole time,
he kills himself.
- Wow.
- I couldn't even follow
it, but I am like, yes.
- That sounds great.
Give it an Emmy.
- All of the robots think
that they are special
and they think that they
are finding a way out of it
but really they're programmed
and everyone's programmed,
even the people that you
think are other humans.
So William thinks that
everyone else is other humans,
he's one of the other humans
but really everyone's a robot
and everyone from all of it
and it's for him to discover
and he didn't actually get...
- That's the game.
- Yeah, and then at the end
he finds out that it was
only him playing the whole
thing and then he kills himself.
- But he owns the whole company.
- I think he invented this.
- That's part of the game.
- That's wild.
- I'm with you!
He could've invented this 30 years ago
and then he's just in
too deep and he forgot,
and now he's like...yeah.
- He's been playing it for that long.
- Exactly, so that's why
he thinks it's real life
and he still has this fake
narrative but it's actually--
I'm with you.
- So if we were to recast
anyone in Westworld,
who would we pick?
- Oprah.
If she were to be cast as Anthony Hopkins,
they are opposite people.
Oprah could never be
nefarious and conniving.
- That's almost scarier though.
That's scarier when
someone tells you something
really (bleep) up with a smile.
Then it's more horrifying.
- We need an Oprah villain.
- Ed Harris' character would be funnier
if it was played by Tiffany Haddish.
I also thing that every
character would be funnier
if they were played by Tiffany Haddish.
Or Kate McKinnon.
- Are we going for a comedy though.
- Of course every character would be
funnier with Tiffany Haddish.
(laughs)
- Would you rather be a
black hat or be a white hat?
- That is deceiving because
he's in a white hat, William,
and he's a bad guy.
- And Logan's in a black hat.
- I think everyone eventually
becomes a black hat.
- I think everybody wears billed hats.
- I think I would just enjoy
my life more in Westworld
as a white hat person.
- No, Big Tit Daisy picks black hat.
- Would you rather be
a host and not know it
or know that you are a host.
- Be a host and not know it.
100%.
- Ignorance is bliss.
- All I'm saying, when
I'm playing the Sims
and I put on freewill
they get very confused
when you all of a sudden force them to do
something else.
It's better if you just
take freewill off the table.
- Would you rather stay
entirely in Sweetwater
or stay entirely in Pariah.
- Sweetwater's like the start town,
Pariah I don't remember.
- Pariah!
Give me some Sodom and Gomorrah!
- Have Logan as your tour
guide or go it alone?
- Go it alone.
- Logan as my tour guide!
- I mean...
(laughter)
- Logan as my tour guide.
- Ben Barnes is hot but I don't
want Logan to introduce me
to the robots I'm gonna (bleep).
I wanna find them on my own.
Call me a hopeless romantic
but I would like to find
my (bleep)-able robots.
Without the influence of others.
- Who needs a robot when you have Logan?
- Spend one night alone
locked in cold storage,
but could choose a host
to keep you company,
or would you rather spend
a night locked in jail,
with no one to keep you company.
- Okay, we know...
- Cold storage?
- Cold storage!
- Wait, why?
- Because then you have a
host to keep you company.
But actually, one night, is not terrible.
- They're all naked, with
their (bleep) Hanging.
- But you know, having sex,
you sweat, you'll get more--
- You're not gonna have sex.
- But you can choose a
host to keep you company.
I mean you could also talk to the host
but that's not where my mind went.
- I will meditate in the
jail, I'm fine, I'll be warm.
- I need alone time.
- You know what we should do?
- What?
- Let's go to my apartment,
we'll turn on my Roomba,
we'll watch it run into walls
and you can also practice
your pick up lines on my Roomba.
- Let's do it.
- Put a vibrator on a
Roomba, welcome to Westworld.
And then I'll be just the
guy who fixes the Roomba
when you've destroyed it.
With your sex.
- Thanks for watching Spoiler Party.
Comment below your thoughts.
Let us know what you think about Westworld
and your predictions.
Below, say how I'm right
and everyone else is wrong
about what's gonna happen
in the next season.
- Don't do it.
- There's no way anything you said
is still gonna be still in this video.
(laughter)
(upbeat music)